and very angrily chases over a tiny
thing of wealth. Um,
and that's the mentality that actually
has destroyed the potential of
blockchain in the context of crypto has
always chased short-term money and
hoarding rather than thinking, well, how
do we make this something that everybody
can step into and use? And so when you
look at our plan, our plan essentially
is to get as many people as possible
engaged involved and using this not just
as a currency but as a an alternative
economy at first and a default economy
in time. And that's when you begin to
look at things like you've been raising
Scott where you say okay so what about
payment solutions? How do we how do we
make payments to people? How do we do
salaries? All of these things can
actually be inculcated into this. I mean